خلف هذه الجبهه يتجدد توتر بين الجيش
الروسي وقوه فاجنر التي تطوق مدينه باخموت
الاوكرانيه بعد اسابيع من تقاذف الاتهامات
التي وصلت حد الشتائم والتخوين في جديد
توتر بين الجانبين يقولوا زعيم فاجنر
افغيني بريغوجين ان الجيش الروسي منع
ممثله من الدخول الى مقر العمليات الخاصه
الروسيه الذي يدير العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
بريكوجين اكد الغاء تصريح ممثله ومنعه من
الوصول الى مقر العمليات مجددا حاجه قوته
الماسه لذخيره وان الخطوط الاماميه في
بخموت مهدده بالانهيار وفي حال انسحاب
فاغنر سيتاثر الجميع
فيما يشبه التسابق بين
الكريمار الانتصار المحتمل في باخموت
مرارا حتى وصل الامر الى المطالبه بتعيينه
وزير للدفاع عبر منصات غير رسميه مواليه
له
قبل بزيارتين لوزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو الى الجبهات احداها الى ماريوبول
والثانيه الى مركز قياده على الجبهه في
دونيتسك
جدا سحبت شركه فان الجبهه ستنهار باكملها
المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا التاخير في
امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو
وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر
جدد
ووفقا
كان وعد بتسليمه اسلحه منذ 23 من فبراير
الفائته لم يتسلم شيئا حتى اللحظه تاخير
فسره باحد الامرين
برقراطيه او خيانه